Barney Teletubbies Bluey of all the
children's TV mascots one of the most
famous has to be Thomas the Tank Engine
but what if Thomas had a more Sinister
side that's what developer 2 Star game
sets out to explore in his upcoming game
choo choo Charles from the island to the
train cult to Charles himself here's
everything to know about choo choo
Charles
choo choo Charles transports you to an
unnamed Island in which your only means
of transportation is a small
single-person train as you navigate the
island on the tracks sometimes debris
blocks your path or you may have to
change the track depending on which
direction you want to go be warned
however that when you leave your Little
Engine That Could the arachnid
locomotive Charles is always stalking
the island and you never know when he
might pop up when you are out of the
train be sure not to wander away too far
from the locomotive or else Charles will
find you and chase you down he also
chases you when you're in the train just
to be clear
in addition to leaving a train to clear
your path you can exit your ride to
scavenge for upgrades and talk to the
settlers of the island for Missions one
of the main ways to find upgradeable
scraps or Collectibles for your train is
to loot the areas taken over by the
Charles worshiping cult that lives on
the island although you do not have any
weapons on your person to take out the
cultists you can lure them back to your
train and use the same weapons that you
use against Charles to fend them off
even using the train itself to flatten
them speaking of weapons let's talk
about the Arsenal and these are all
named by the community which I think is
pretty neat the derailleur that's your
default machine gun with low damage but
medium range and medium fire rate the
bug spray a standard flamethrower with
low damage the lowest range but a
massive fire rate the Boomer a rocket
launcher with massive damage but low
range and fire rate and Bob the long
range option with medium damage but high
range and decent fire rate Combat with
Charles has you switching weapons
constantly depending on the damage you
want to deal and how much space you want
to make between Charles and your train
remember those scraps be sure to hold on
to those because they can help you heal
your train during the heat of battle
Charles only takes a little damage
during each encounter before he Retreats
back to stalking the island so be
diligent about how you upgrade and
outfit your train
two star games has detailed that he has
about three main story missions to be
able to upgrade the guns and train to
take down Charles there are some side
missions that involve collecting orbs
from the cultists that will summon
Charles for the final showdown two star
games has said that if you're rushing
through you can complete the game in
about two hours but it will take most
players about three to four hours to
complete
outside of his explanation that the
cultists are around the island for the
sole purpose of gathering offerings and
sacrifices to feed Charles there isn't
much in the way of a story two star
games has stated that the game starts in
one place and ends in one place meaning
the opening and ending are always the
same but how you get there could change
depending on how you play in his
development update videos two star games
does hint a lot at the potential story
that hasn't been released yet namely why
Charles and the island exist in the
first place I guess we'll have to wait
to launch to find out
choo choo Charles is being developed by
two star games which consists of one
person Gavin Eisen bites he has been
making the game for just over a year and
has been documenting his journey
primarily on Tick Tock but also YouTube
and Twitter I'll tag his info in the
description so you can check it out too
although choo choo Charles is his most
recent game two star games got their
start with my beautiful paper smile a
handcrafted horror game in the style of
a demonic Sketchbook it's available to
play right now on Steam as of the
published date of this video choo choo
Charles is only available on Steam
although Gavin has said that he would
love to Port it to consoles at some
point in the next year Gavin also notes
that he will not be moving on to other
projects and supporting the game in the
months after release even though there
will be no dedicated multiplayer mode
choo choo Charles is available now to
wishlist on Steam and will cost 19.99 US
dollars with the price localized for
every region the game releases on
December 9th
choo choo Charles is the latest in the
growing trend of childhood mascots
turned demonic Killers remember that
Winnie the Pooh horror movie that comes
out next year although I don't know how
I feel about a demonic version of one of
my favorite childhood shows I am excited
to face off against Charles and his
merry band of cultists I'll link all of
Gavin's socials in the description catch
me on Twitter at Stewie review and
thanks for watching